[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to PJ's K
class today we would like to build is
this really common hello ring for
engagement ring and its really popular
what we need to do is quite simple we
will need the following commands first
we're going to use the revolve and it
will help to build a cup underneath the
stone then we will use the pipe tool to
make the prong and once we make one set
of the small stone
we'll use polar array and I recommend
you record a history so you can change
the prong position finally we'll use the
sweep one command to make the ring shank
let's get started before we stop your
model they are two video I would like to
argue to take a look on it it is on my
youtube channel at PJ chain design on
the YouTube and you will see this video
is showing you a lot of terminology how
to how to set the stone and telling tell
you like what part is what's done what
is the proper way to hold a stone and
the other video is to how to build a
diamond in Rhino 5 and this has two part
on it it's a two video for how to build
a diamond and once you build a diamond
you can stretch it make it into your
oval shape if you like so let's go back
to the right now
first of all we have a strong in our
model and in my case my is above five
point five millimeters then we draw and
we want to make a cup underneath it so
let me open another layer let's use this
layer for the setting so I will draw a
square and I want it to be longer than
the qulet I am going to move it here
underneath the stone but tilted a little
bit so I'll cup well be tapered one
thing to pay attention you don't want
this in this position because you're
going to see a lot of metal and that
will make you store smaller so we want
to roughly get it as close as possible
and if it is too long we can always you
know trim you later so what I do is I'm
going to use the revolve come in and
type is zero as my center point hold
shift and click on anywhere with that
will be 90 degree and then I want to
revolve 360 degree so I get the cup
there second we need to make a prompt
and we need to know where is the prone
position here so I'm using this curve
and my all snap as on as you can see
snap on my end point I mean can light up
from you and I want to continue going up
a little bit there
alright so that would be my curve and I
can pipe this one and roughly about 0.8
millimeters so radius will be point four
millimeter long if it's really about a
propulsion if you feel like this is a
little bit too small you can make it
bigger but the key is you don't want to
prom to be overwhelming because that
will
make the zone smaller okay so now I need
to move my prawn just a little bit lower
in the right position okay all I need to
do now is to use the rotate and make
sure copy equal YES on the command bar
and snap to the zero and I want to have
four prong so one two three and four so
I have four prawn there so we are done
for the first one and then we can rotate
it by 45 degrees to be in the right
position okay let's make a copy of
center stone ctrl-c and ctrl-v then we
want to select everything beside one of
the stone and then we're going to hide
it so now we only have this stone okay
let's go it down to I'm Italian scale it
down to roughly about two millimeter and
it really depends on your design in my
case is roughly two millimeter for this
demonstration then we're going to do
exactly the same thing we just did so on
the right view
I'm going to throw a rectangular and you
need to be longer to cut in cut into
inside of the Ring
and then we're going to use revolve this
guy and do 360 degree and then so we
have that cup going to do the same thing
we are going to have we're going to draw
Booker a straight line and I wanted this
line to extend by follow the angles or
what I do is I move it back here and
then I see the tab key and then moving
up you'll see a white line and that way
you will have a really straight line and
let's go ahead and type it so 0.3
millimeter in radius
that's 0.6 millimeter in diameter so
that's one of it and then we are going
to using the rotate and then I'm gonna
Center is a zero and copy equal yes and
first it's 120 and the second is 240 so
I will have three-prong evenly and I'm
going to again rotate Paula I'm going to
turn on I'm going to move this guy down
a little bit and turn now while we were
hiding so in this case I need to have
this guy with a 180 degree and we want
to get it first close as possible and of
course we want to tell to the angle it
look more graceful in this way and
moving in a little bit okay it look
really nice
all we need to do now is to polar array
the whole things so I'm going to go to
the tab view and then go into a
transform a raise polar going to set the
center to the zero and guessing roughly
about self of them just need to make
sure that the stone is not touching
stone like this if it does we might need
to move the original one down a little
bit so let's do it again we want to move
it out a little bit okay and this time
let's record history go to transform a
reign polar array those object Center is
0 12 so let's take a look on that it's
better and I just notice that I have
double prong here
so in fact we just need two prong
instead of three so I want to show you
this so we want to go back and did it
one of them and we'll do the same thing
like polar away oh and then we want to
make sure our history record a history
and let's do the polar array select the
object and Center is a zero twelve of
them and now I don't have a repeating
prong but if you take a look on the
prong the prong is kind of cutting it
very like on both sides so actually I
need to have this prong moving up a
little bit so I'm gonna move this
because we have a record history so
every prom will move along with it so
now is it better so we have all this
ready so what we can do is we can select
all of them and then we want to do
bullying unit it will tell you you will
break the history but it's okay because
we no longer unique history there so we
will have a whole things ready now it's
time to make the ring King I just need a
simple ring think so what I'm going to
do is to draw rectangular turn on my oh
snap and then again this depends on the
design this tutorial once again is I
Boyd so I want to move the Gumbel and I
want to use the Move tool to move to the
midpoint to the court and let me explore
this guy and it puts explored and did it
one side and I want to make this ability
curve there
alright then let me join them together
and give them a little bit radius
I say coin three so they all look a lil
be rounded okay so I have one here and
I'm going to me roll to the other side
all right and on the top why we need to
make a song little bit lower
okay on the top I need to have this
profile going here so I'm going to round
this round you and then I'm going to
rotate it from the center and you want
to actually get into the model so that
way this you can pulling them together
but if you look at the perspective it's
a little bit too wide and you can change
it to make it the form a small interest
so I'm going to make it more narrow so
you will look paper the same form is
going to me roll to the other side so so
we'll get there so let me just hide as
temporary so you will see what I'm doing
so you see the line here the curve here
and the curve there let me turning into
the right color so we'll see better all
right so what we need to do now is we
are going to use the sweep so it's sweep
one
it's the rail and this is the
cross-section
all right and I like to keep them all in
the inside of the rain check and make
sure they face the same direction all
right and we don't need to close this
week and now remember this is on these
surface we need to cap this there and
you can type to come in so cap and pick
up your surface and now they are 10 ok
turn number we were hiding all we need
to do now is to find our curve folder
inside the ring shank we go into the
solid extra planet curve straight and I
want to make sure it's solid equal yes
both I equal yes all right then we need
to do is bowling difference the setting
will be cut it out by the cube remember
whatever you want to keep clicking first
on the bowling difference then we just
need to bullying unit those but if
you're going to have to tone for example
this is going to be the yellow goal and
the other one is wykel and then you just
keep them separately okay full rendering
prefers all right that's what we have
for the hollow ring today and I hope you
enjoyed and I will see you in my other
video thank you for watching
[Music]
you